I've been waiting for an opportunity to
rerun this week's classic interview it's
with Anthony Papa and I interviewed him
back in 2015 and he's from the drug
policy alliance and he's actually a
victim of extreme drug sentencing and
this is so important because we are
talking a lot lately about these pardons
from President Trump we talked about the
pardoning of Alice Marie Johnson we've
talked about the possibility of
pardoning others in the future but also
what seemed to be sort of like political
or optics or wasted pardons from Donald
Trump and so in reviewing this interview
with Anthony Pappa what I want to think
about as we listen to it is when we
prioritize pardons what should we be
thinking of what should the principles
and priorities be and with that let's
check out my interview from October of
2015 with Anthony Papa I'm joined today
by Anthony Papa whose manager of media
relations for the drug policy Alliance
he also has personal experience with the
criminal justice system and the war on
drugs he was sentenced to 15 years to
life and ultimately served 12 years in
sing-sing Anthony it's great to have you
let's start for people who may not be
familiar with your story talk to us a
little bit about your conviction thanks
for having me on your show it was the
first time nonviolent drug offender in
1985 I made the biggest mistake of my
life I got involved with drug activity a
person a bold on my bowling team asked
me why I was coming late to legal the
time and I told Mike my car keeps
breaking down he said why don't you fix
it I didn't have any money well from
that point on he introduced me to
someone who was dealing drugs in the
bowling alleys in Westchester County he
asked me if I wanted to make a fast
dollar I said for what he says deliver
an envelope from the Bronx to Mount
Vernon and I'll give you five hundred
dollars at first I said no because I
knew it was about and I passed it passed
it by a couple of months later it was
Christmastime things got desperate I
needed money and he asked me again nice
I'll do it so I wanted to bring in this
envelope containing four and a half
ounces of cocaine up from the Bronx to
Mount Vernon but I walked into a police
sting operation 20 cops came out of
nowhere was placed under arrest and I
did everything I could do wrong and
eventually I was sentenced to 15 years
to life under the Rockefeller drug laws
which mandates mandatory minimum
sentencing and were you did this go to
trial or did you take a plea deal no I
took a plea they actually offered me
three to life because they knew I wasn't
a drug dealer but I didn't want to leave
my wife and my seven-year-old daughter
and I went to trial and it was a big
mistake because I got walloped with to
15 of life sentences one for sales one
for possession of the four and a half
ounces of cocaine but since that was the
first time nonviolent drug offender the
judge gave me a break ran the sentence
together so I only had 115 a life
sentence I served at st. st.
correctional facility and talk to us a
little bit about that I mean were you
what what types of other offenders
were you imprisoned with was it was it
similar to the crime you had been
convicted over was a drastically
different violent crime etc it was it
was a mixed bag I mean you know
everybody I went to sing sings a
maximum-security prison so you you're
sentenced along with others that has
sentenced for murder rape I mean just
heinous crime and it was a nightmare
experience to say the least you know
when I was in prison I was lost I didn't
know what to do I was my identity who I
was in life and became prisoner number
85 80 20 30 7 what saved my life was my
discovery of art we're through another
prisoner I learned that I was an artist
prison is a very existential environment
and what I mean by that is there's
something mystical about being in prison
in a 6x9 cage for many years you find
out about yourself so for me I found out
that I was an artist
and three years later 1988 I was sitting
in my cell
picked up a mirror looked in the mirror
I saw an individual's gonna spend the
most productive years his life in a cage
and I painted the self-portrait
tiredly 15 to life seven years later
wound up with the Whitney Museum of
American Art while I was in prison I got
a lot of publicity on my case and
Governor George Pataki granted me
executive clemency and while you were
while you were incarcerated you also did
many things that that other inmates
don't do right I mean you earn two
bachelor's degree you got a masters
degree you as you mentioned you you had
George Pataki grant you clemency after
you were released you did some acting
you are on HBO's Oz you've been in
several films but even with all that
notwithstanding it you you still have
have been at the mercy of the challenges
that exist for for formerly incarcerated
persons right I mean talk about that a
little bit yeah I mean it was a tough
experience you know it's a rude
awakening
and you spend an enormous amount of time
in prison and then suddenly you're free
like these people coming out now there's
about 6,000 that are coming out under
these new changes in the law right and
they're about to enter society and
they're in for a rude awakening
it's tough every step of the way for an
ex-offender you're blocked with passing
employment it's just it's hard for
ex-offenders you're you're labeled an
ex-offender and you wear that label for
the rest of your life for me it's my 18
year of freedom and I still feel the
stigma of being an ex-offender
I just wrote about it a new book I
actually had to address this issue of
people coming home it's called men and
women returning home in an age of reform
it's available
Kindle on Amazon and basically what I
try to do is use my stories and are
telling men and women who were coming
home about my experiences because prison
doesn't end at the prison wall goes
beyond the wall it affects families
loved ones those on the outside and one
thing people won't realize is that when
you come into the free world from prison
you drag along with you all the baggage
that you use to survive imprisonment all
the coping mechanisms and you bring them
with you in the free world and at times
they suddenly appear and you have no
control over them and it's a very
dangerous situation which when this
occurs look for it a little bit about
that I mean in thinking of sort of the
broader problems we have we have the
sort of status quo of the war on drugs
we have mandatory minimums we have in in
many cases not in your particular case
but we have plea deals and the sort of
plea deal structure that is set up to to
really hurt a lot of nonviolent
offenders you have the sort of punitive
nature of incarceration as opposed to
rehabilitative where what's the what's
the top priority or in other words
what's the lowest hanging fruit that
could be tackled first that would have
the most impact
you mean when when when people are
returning to the free world just in
general in terms of reform what what are
the first changes that might have the
big impact is it talking about mandatory
minimums is it about what it what the
paesan's are like etc I think that
mandatory minimums have become a poison
that has destroyed our criminal justice
system
President Obama is speaking about this
and there's legislation now that exists
actually bipartisan legislation which
has passed the Senate waiting for
Congress to act on it which would reduce
mandatory minimum sentencing what
mandatory minimum sentence he does it
takes away the discretion of the judge
look at the totality of facts so for
example in my case I got 15 years to
life as a first-time nonviolent drug
offender that didn't matter what
mattered was the weight involved of the
drug the fauna have ounces of cocaine so
under the Rockefeller drug laws which
mandate mandatory minimum sentencing I
passed this envelope with four and a
half ounces two ounce sale or four ounce
possession Matan I got arrested would
give you a 15 to life sentence or better
men and women have received these
sentences 15 20 25 years mandatory
minimum sentencing and these laws have
become under the federal sentencing
these were the original laws in 1973 one
reenacted of the Rockefeller drug laws
it eventually became mandatory minimum
sentencing laws in the federal
government where the Act every state had
some sort of mandatory minimum
sentencing law this bill those laws that
destroyed our system it has increased
prisons to the capacity where the
prisons are exploding and it seems now
because of it became a monetary issue
everybody politicians from the left from
the right are getting together and
realizing that it's it's not
cost-efficient these laws it's a waste
of tax dollars a waste of human lives
money could be better spent on needy
communities to put shoes on streamers
children so politicians are not I'm not
acting on this issue and with the lead
from President Obama
hopefully mass incarceration will end
all right we've been speaking with
Anthony papa
I'll remind you the new book is an open
letter to men and women returning home
in an age of reform he's with the drug
policy Alliance thanks so much for
sharing your story with us yeah if you
want to know more about our organization
is drug policy org or you could go to my
website 15 to life
dot-com and see my art and my story
thanks very much for having me as a
guest